so Michael I wanted to thank you again
for coming in today and a chance to
review your resume and I was actually
quite impressed so you have a background
in accounting and you've actually
transitioned doing more autonomous
systems type work recently so there's
one project and particularly be really
interested in hearing about which was
using convolutional neural nets in
self-driving cars I was wondering if you
wouldn't mind kind of taking me through
a little bit of that project some of the
challenges that you faced some of the
methods that you used and if there's
anything that you would have liked to
have done that you just didn't have a
chance to yet sure so in that project I
was originally attempting to come up
with a deep learning approach that was
more robust than what we had done in the
class around advanced lane finding so in
the project we had used more classic
computer vision techniques where we use
different colored gradients etc to kind
of go through and find where the lane
lines like they were in the image then
we had to do perspective transformations
where we essentially got a bird's-eye
view of the road all this took quite a
bit of computational power so it wasn't
really real-time I believe it was
running at roughly three FPS or so which
doesn't really work in real world
applications you're not updating fast
enough so in this approach I wanted to
get something that truly could go at
real speed around 30 fps or so as well
as being more robust than what I did
before the original one wasn't very good
on curves for instance once they got up
to too big of a curve the algorithm just
would stop working and run off the page
essentially and think that the lines
were going straight when they were
really going curved so along with
gathering that training data then which
I went out and essentially just drove
around my car you know had my phone up
and taking in video images and
extracting those frames out for my
training data I then moved on to my
network and my network was built using a
similar architecture to Signet which was
a paper I read at the time I'm probably
gonna diagram it out can you show me
that really quick I'm not really
familiar with that one so cygnets basic
idea it starts out like a normal
convolutional neural network and usually
a convolutional neural network comes out
with a input image coming in as your
input and then you have successive
layers that are smaller convolutional
layers
and a lot of times in another network
you might have like a fully connected
layer at this point but the difference
with a fully convolutional neural
network which is what segments had in it
was that on the flip side you come back
with what are called d convolutional
layers that slowly get larger and have
this semantic output where it you know
potentially is the same size of your
image or you could resize it back up to
that but every single pixel in that
output is actually a different class in
my case it was whether you were the lane
or not the lane so in doing so then I'm
basically doing binary classification
between the two there's also
applications where you have more classes
say a vehicle or pedestrian etc in my
case though I was just wanting to
improve on my lane finding algorithm and
so I just looked at the lane itself some
of the other applications also looked
for just free space on the road which I
thought you know well I don't really
want my car to be driving on the
opposite side of the road so I really
only want to know what my own lane is
here one of the challenges that I ran
into first was in actually getting this
to fully work and train correctly
because semantic segmentation networks
actually also use a technique that are
called skip layers now skip layers can
very easily be used to essentially go
from you know skipping entire middle
section of the network or they could
also be used just to skip between to two
layers or more layers however many you
want now this is important because when
you've extracted some more advanced
features but you've also gone through
max pooling layers a lot of times losing
information about where in the image a
certain thing occurred so if I'm trying
to classify every pixel it's important
to have that information at the end and
be able to draw that back now another
thing that happens is when you perform
Bret backpropagation you need to make
sure that the information is actually
going all the way through because if you
get a really deep Network
backpropagation can have what's called a
vanishing gradient problem where you're
doing so much of the chain rule and
multiplication going back that it starts
diminishing that gradient and
essentially you don't really feed any of
the air to those earlier layers and
they're really deep network and this
helps fix that problem because you
actually
being over missing something
multiplication in the middle and that
backpropagation signal continues all the
way back to the front of the network hmm
really interesting nice thank you yeah
thanks